the far right has never had it so good
in britain
the most senior counter-terrorism police
officer has said that the
febrile atmosphere created by brexit
could radicalize potential far-right
extremists
and convicted criminals stephen
yaxley-lennon also known as tommy
robinson
has convinced thousands of people that
being held to account for breaking the
law makes him a victim
and a martyr it's widely accepted that
we have been too
slow to act in the face of the hate that
is gripping this country
so news that lennon will no longer be
able to profit from his poisonous
youtube posts
is welcome the google owned social media
site alongside paypal
banned him last week from profiting in
response to
among other things a video celebrating
him punching a migrant
i believe in freedom of speech but our
constitution in britain
the britain far-right extremists claim
to feel so patriotic about
is based on the rule of law which makes
inciting hatred a crime
it's about time we began to apply it
[Music]
so um i don't think anything i heard you
say that i can disagree with
um specifically but i want to broaden
the conversation out of it
um i do worry that first of all i don't
think it's a free speech issue because
youtube is a privately owned company it
can choose its own terms of service
what i worry about are related issues
one is
um what i have been calling a cultural
bias online
and that is that uh the uh tech giants
whether it's twitter facebook or social
media companies youtube
and and others are very quick and very
responsive to
what they perceive as racism and
far-right extremism online
and yet meanwhile so for example twitter
took tommy robinson down it also took
down milo annapolis and
carl benjamin and a few others have been
removed from twitter meanwhile
twitter the same company um still has
operating officially
terrorist organizations such as hamas
and hezbollah and
they still have accounts in english and
in arabic and
and the examples continue beyond
violence to even just mere when i say
mir
uh legal forms of islamist extremism and
i think the inconsistency
present on social media companies and
this is just on the islamist extremism
debate
can also then further fuel the far right
i think the second point
is these tech companies such as youtube
have been terribly slow
generally in taking things down and if
you look at this um
look at how much they earn so a company
like youtube
so more than one billion hours of
youtube videos are watched every day now
that turns into
according to some estimates eight
billion dollars in revenue in 2015. now
if you
earned as a company just youtube not
google as a whole alphabet
but just the youtube division of of
alphabet uh which is the new name for
google
you earn that much money and you can't
be bothered
to hire people to a put down a
consistent and transparent policy and
then b
enforce it and you look at the number of
for example pedophilic
uh or semi pedophilic videos on on
youtube it's disgusting that what these
companies have been allowed to
get away with you were talking about
inconsistencies i think there's also a
hypocrisy around youtube because
because tommy robinson and his ilk have
had as you just said before they've had
freeride for a very long time
and youtube have made lots of money out
of that and they've been throwing
adverts onto his site for a very long
time
and all of a sudden they've decided
that's wrong but i i just i don't know
whether you've heard of a woman called a
nadine strossen she's a she's a
scholar an american scholar and she's
written a book called hate and it's
about hate speech and
its effects and she says speech is this
i just wanted the quote speech is
powerful and can afflict pain
but the cure of censorship is worse than
the disease of hate she said worse than
speech's potential to harm individuals
in society
is the government's power to do likewise
by enforcing hate speech laws and i
think
there's a lot of truth in that and if
we're you know shouldn't a nation
of of adults be confident enough in its
capacity
to defeat terrible opinions in an open
marketplace
because then they become powerless
rather than force them underground where
they become more powerful can i
challenge you on that
if they're adults yes but if you come
back to the point that
afwa made about neil basu and he's the
national police lead for counter-terror
and he's the mets assistant commissioner
for counter-terror
and he responded to the fact that it's
primary school children now
who are being and on both sides not just
the far right but sorry not both sides
all sorts of various
primary schools yes adults probably are
hopefully
well enough educated to process and
those who are saying can we
primary school children are being
deliberately targeted by these let me
just get a legal out and just say
and that is where i think we've got a
major problem and that is where you're
absolutely right
sky news couldn't put out this sort of
unchecked material lbc we couldn't
broadcast
the the daily mirror couldn't but they'd
be closed down and none of those
organizers
made that kind of money let me say just
say what youtube says because you
mentioned them a lot let me just get
this and then i promise i'll yield
uh we have suspended ads on tommy
robinson's youtube channel as it
breaches our advertising policies
youtube said it believed strongly in
freedom of expression but it had a
responsibility to protect its community
of creators
viewers and advertisers from what it
called derogatory and disparaging
content there's no official comment from
mr robinson
but he said it's all continued
censorship i think we can all agree that
this is a question of balance i mean i
i'm i used to be a lawyer who worked on
free speech cases i believe very
strongly in what you say carol that we
do need a free marketplace of ideas
we don't want to sense people who find
difficult free speech is meaningless
unless it's the freedom
to say things that people don't like to
hear right so i completely agree but
that's also why we have laws that
protect us against speech that is
designed to incite hatred
and you know i think you're right majid
there is uh there are
there's not a level of application among
different hate groups
but what happens online is the mirror
opposite of real life
in which uh there have has been more
concerted police action towards some
kinds of extremism than it has towards
the far right and that's why i think
people are now acknowledging we've been
too so i'm going to bring phil in but i
just want something
i i want to just read you what hope not
hate say about this which is that
the far right are utterly reliant on
social media and crowdfunding platforms
to keep their coffers plump
youtube made the right choice but all
too often they and others are far too
slow
in reacting when these paypal patriots
take to the airwaves
to spread their poison and violence
right
i'm i'm i'm of a mind with this that if
you take
if you take tommy down you've got to
take down hammers you've got to take
down all these other people as well
which they don't so that's not that's my
first one
yeah the second point is when you've
still got people like diane abbott who
won't
acknowledge that what she said about the
ira and her
comments were exact often she said
something about her haircut style has
changed but she
her views have as well it's not good
enough i think tommy gets hung
drawn and quartered for a pass that he's
had are you comparing diane abbott to
tommy robinson phil
they both they both got checked past as
far as i'm concerned and i don't i don't
like what
be breaking standards what are those
standards what are they saying because
he can say that surely you know there's
there's other people like hamas and that
touting their wares on there so i think
that question there is is what are what
are your what
what about the tech companies don't put
out transparent standards that's part of
the problem
that is the whole issue it doesn't
matter it doesn't mean
that certain people shouldn't have been
taken down it means at least if we know
what those standards are we can then
have this
part of the problems we can't have this
conversation because when youtube took
down
and and sorry a patron recently took
down carl benjamin that twitter first
band
they refused to say why they did so they
should be
should be asked yeah they should be made
suspending tommy robinson's account
don't you
do i agree with it i i don't know what
for i don't know why they
are you familiar with the story and
magic covered it very well of this uh
refugee boy jamal
syrian from syrian refugee family who
was who was abused and waterboarded in
the playground
i don't know in in um uh ramayana was
majid uh huddersfield huddersfield
um well you you don't remember that
story and and it prompted a huge
outpouring of sympathy for the family
and and money was raised to relocate
them and it turned out his sister had
also been bullied and abused at school
tommy robinson took to social media can
i give him to promote
something which was later found to be
untrue that this boy had been abusing
white english girls right now and he's
been through and i just want to make the
point by the way that tommy robinson's
one of his main strategies is to shut
down
other people using threats of libel he
goes around threatening other people who
have spoken
freely and claiming that they have he
wants to see
the idea that he's the kind of defender
where do these where do these lines in
the sound get drawn who draws
well these are private companies they
can define their own terms but we at
least we need to know what those terms
are so we don't fall foul of them but
currently they're a bit opaque
but they have the right to do so phil
because they're private companies and
i'm going to close down this
conversation or since it shall return
because we move on to
other matters